Let's see what we can do here.
Okay.
Here I felt a little bit distracted because I thought I was going too close to the camera.
And in that part I was worried about the technique because I had been getting that move the
outer block wrong.
It was supposed to be higher and I kept doing it lower than usual.
So I was a bit distracted with that as well.
Yeah overall here I'm very distracted because again the block, I have to memorize what hand
goes up first.
So I wouldn't feel in the zone.
I would say the first half of it I've got all the techniques down so I feel in the zone
but the remaining half I don't feel in the zone.
I'm like more focused on technique so I get a little bit distracted.
Okay.
So from the number 4, you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern.
And then with that one, any mistakes that you make, if it's a minor mistake, you get a minus of 0.1.
If it's a major mistake, you get minus 0.3.
So I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So with a minor mistake, it's a very, very small thing.
So let's say we're doing an outer block.
If it's not your shoulder height, maybe it's a little bit lower, or maybe it's a tiny bit higher, that's a minor mistake.
So that's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be, you're supposed to do an outer block in the pattern, but you forget and you say you do a re-transtruct instead.
So that would be a major mistake.
So with a minor mistake, let's say pattern 1 for example, there's 20 steps.
It's not uncommon to have up to maybe 4.
14, 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns, sorry, in the 20 steps.
So the reason for that one being, it needs to be absolutely perfect to get, to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So it's not uncommon, let's say there's 20 steps and you made, let's say 15 mistakes.
So what would that be?
So we'll leave that there on this side, and we'll come back and we'll just calculate the score at the end.
So...
A major mistake, say you're supposed to turn to the left, when you turn to the right, that would be a major mistake.
So obviously we do want to try and avoid any of these major mistakes.
So, after we've done our pattern, that's when we move on to the presentation side.
So the presentation, as you can see, it's from a score of 6.
This 6 is actually split up into 3 parts.
So we have 1, 2, 3 here.
So with this one, for a score of 2 is your power and speed.
Your rhythm is also a score of 2, and your expression of energy is also scored out of 2 as well.
So, we'll start off with the power and speed.
So with this one, whether it's your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything that you do,
you need to be nice and strong, and it has to be fast as well.
So it's one thing to have a very strong punch, or a very fast punch, but it has to be both strong and fast to get high in that category.
So the next part is your rhythm.
So the rhythm, when you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern.
It's not just really fast all the way through, it's not slow all the way through.
There's a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect to it as well.
So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm, and that's also scored out of 2.
The last bit is your expression of energy.
So, what is expression of energy?
So that's basically how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern.
So, say you're doing your pattern really well, it's really fast and it's strong, your rhythm is really great,
but you're not shouting very loud, or you can kind of tell, the judges can kind of tell that you're not really confident,
you're a little bit nervous, so that's what we need to kind of improve on as well.
So, I'll just come around to this side.
So, with this one, for colour belts and black belts, it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So, if you're a colour belt, you'll actually,
your average, so where the judges actually mark you from,
it's actually from a 1.1.
So, this is your average.
So, say you did alright, you did average compared to everyone else,
your score for 1, 2 and 3, it'll start from a 1.1.
So, if you're less than average in the judges' eyes,
you might go down to, say for your power and speed, you might get a 1, or even a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So, each individual category, you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt, generally, depending on the competition,
you will be scored from a 1.3.
So, 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So, say your power and speed was above average,
you might get scored a 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average, it wasn't amazing.
It might be just a 1.3, but let's say you didn't shout very loud.
So, your expression of energy, your average was 1.3,
it might drop to, say, a 1.0.
So, with this one, we'll comment down from this side.
So, with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10.
So, let's see.
For presentation, we had 1.7, 1, 2, 3.
So, you had a 3.7.
Let's say you made 15 mistakes.
So, with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged
if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
This is with the judges.
We have three judges usually at the panel,
and each judge, obviously, is very subjective.
So, from their point of view,
you might have made a lot of mistakes,
or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So, that's why we have the three judges,
and we average it out as well.
Okay, so, say we did our 15 mistakes,
very small mistakes.
So, if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5.
So, you go 4.0 minus 1.5,
which equals 2.5.
So, this would be your accuracy score.
So, with our presentation like before,
we're saying we got a 3.7 here.
So, we add these numbers after the judges have finished scoring.
So, you would get, for this pattern, a 6.2,
which is actually very good.
So, I'll just talk a little bit more now about this number here.
So, if you're a color belt,
if you're a yellow or above,
and you do your patterns,
it's not uncommon, generally for a color belt,
the average is about a 4 to 5.
So, if you get a number between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern,
that's actually generally considered pretty good.
So, anything above that, you can consider yourself pretty good.
If you're a black belt, the average would say,
because we're talking here about the higher presentation
as an average,
anything from 5 to 6 is actually considered pretty good.
And anything over a 7 is actually considered almost world-class.
So, if you get a 7 for any of your patterns,
you generally need to pat yourself on the back
because you did an amazing job.
So, we just went through our pointe scoring.
So, just remember, accuracy is a 4.0.
Presentation is a 6.0.
Accuracy is judged during your pattern.
Presentation is after.
And then we get the two scores that we add up.
And we get that number.
So, with this one, obviously,
say I was judge number 1.
I would give you a 6.2.
There was another judge on the other side.
Maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did.
So, maybe this one would be a little bit lower.
It might be a 5 point something.
Another judge on the other side.
They scored a little bit higher.
So, we'd get the three numbers
and then we'd average that as well.
So, I hope this helped you guys.
So, make sure you enjoy your pointe competitions.
And make sure, obviously,
you record down your numbers as well.
Can you see these minor errors?
Take them in real time.
Add the errors.
And then major errors.
We cannot pause the video this time.
So, you have to rate yourself while you're watching.
Like a real judge.
And then after the Poomsae power and speed,
coordination, and expression of energy,
then we click continue.
So, you can practice for 7 minutes.
So, let's do this.
Now, some Jennie is using her phone.
голос responsibilities